i have to ask
uh about beautiful artificial life
systems
or evolution computation systems uh
cellular automata to me
like i remember it was as a game changer
for me early on in life when i saw
conway's game of life who recently
passed away unfortunately
it's beautiful how much
complexity can emerge from such simple
rules i i just don't
somehow that simplicity is
such a powerful illustration and also
humbling because it feels like
i personally from my perspective
understand almost nothing about
this world because because like my
intuition fails completely
how complexity can emerge from such
simplicity like my intuition fails i
think is the biggest problem i have
um do you find systems like that
beautiful is there do you do you think
about cellular automata because
cellular tama don't really have um
and many other artificial life systems
don't necessarily have an objective
maybe maybe that's a wrong way to
say it it's almost like
it's just evolving and creating
and there's not even a good definition
of what it means to create something
complex and interesting and surprising
all those words that he said um
is there some some of those systems you
find uh beautiful
yeah yeah and uh similarly evolution
does not have a goal
uh it is responding to uh current
situation
uh and so survival then if it creates
more complexity and therefore we have
something that we perceive as progress
but that's not what evolution is
inherently
uh said to do uh and yeah that's
that's really fascinating how a simple
set of rules or simple uh mappings
can um from from how from
such simple mappings complexity can
emerge
so it's a question of emergence and
self-organization uh
and um the game of life is one of the
simplest ones
and very visual and therefore it drives
home the point that it's possible that
non-linear uh interactions uh and uh
and this kind of complexity can emerge
emerge from them
and biology and evolution is along the
same lines we have
simple representations dna if you really
think of it it's not that complex
um there's a long sequence of them
there's lots of them but it's a very
simple representation
and similar evolutionary computation
whatever string or tree
representation we have and the
operations you know the amount of code
that's required to manipulate those is
really really little and and of course
came alive even less
so how complexity emerges from such
simple principles that's that's
absolutely fascinating um the challenge
is to be able to control it and
guide it and direct it so that it
becomes useful
and like game of life is fascinating to
look at and and evolution all the forms
that come out is fascinating but can we
actually make it
useful for us and efficient because if
you actually think about
each of the cells in the game of life as
a living organism
there's a lot of death that has to
happen to create anything interesting
yeah and so i guess the questions for us
humans that are mortal and then life
ends quickly
we want to kind of hurry up and make
sure
we make sure we take evolution uh uh
the trajectory that is a little bit more
efficient than uh
the alternatives and that that is one
something we talked about earlier that
evolution competition is very uh
impatient yeah we have we have a goal we
want it
right away whereas this biology has a
lot of time and
and deep deep time and weak pressure and
large populations
uh one great example of of this is the
novelty search
so evolution and computation where you
don't
actually specify a fitness goal
something that
is your actual thing that you want but
you just reward
solutions that are different from what
you've seen before yeah
nothing else yeah and you know what you
actually discover things that are
interesting and useful that way
um guest danny and joe lima did this one
study where they actually
tried to evolve walking behavior on
robots and that's actually we talked
about earlier where
your robot actually failed in all kinds
of ways and eventually discovered
something that was
a very efficient walk uh and and it was
because they if they rewarded things
that were different
that you were able to discover something
uh and i think that this is crucial um
because in order to be really different
from what you already have
you have to utilize what is there in a
domain to create something really
different
so you have encoded the uh fundamentals
of your world
and then you make changes to those
fundamentals you get further away
so that's probably what's happening in
these systems of emergence
that the fundamentals are there
and when you follow those fundamentals
you get into points and some of those
are
actually interesting and useful now even
in that robotic walker simulation there
was a large
set of garbage uh but among them there
were some of these
you know gems and then those are the
ones that somehow you have to outside
recognize and make useful uh but these
kind of productive systems
if you code them the right kind of
principles um i think that they
that encode the structure of the domain
then you will get to these solutions and
the discoveries
you